and you've written so many books in the
meantime so I'm finishing my seventh
book right now this is another poetry
book or this is a book this this is
another another book that goes back to
the industry it's called slump oh okay
and it's about what to do as a creative
person during that month or three
between projects or when you have no
idea when the next project is coming
because there was nothing lined up when
you finished the last one that sounds
great it is horrifying if you have no
idea what's happening or you haven't
done it before like I can remember
sitting in my office at La Center
Studios when MTV's fear was wrapping up
and I sat at my desk and I just cried
because I was like this is it I'm never
going to work again this is in
2001 21 years ago I was like oh I'm
never going to work again and now I've
done 47 shows wow you have to figure out
you know that the the aerial view of
your career is lots of dots and dashes
and hopefully you have way more dashes
than dots in that you get to work for a
long period of of time and then you
don't work and then you come in on a
project for a week or you come in on a
project for three days and then you find
another job that's going to last you
know two months or three months and
that's just the that's just the way
things are in the freelance Universe
you're gonna it's going to be feast or
famine you know you're going to buy a
house and then you're going to be
terrified that you're going to lose the
house you're going to buy a Mercedes and
then you're gonna be like I'm going to
lose the car because I spent all this
money and then I didn't plan I you know
I didn't know what to do when the you
know when things were down I have had so
much money wash over my hands on huge
projects where I'm just like this is
great and then I invest and then I
immediately have to pull the money back
out because for three months nothing
happens because there wasn't anything
going do you think that if we're in a
slump and this is probably you're going
into this in your book forgive me if I'm
revealing part uh but that we need that
fear because you know there's some
people that believe in this is going to
sound very you know Airy fairy but the
abundance of the universe and sometimes
those people they're waiting a little
too long for things that is true and I
also think that there is a an idea that
once you have momentum you will always
have
momentum and it just doesn't work that
way it's there if you're not actively
leaning
into things all the time which is if you
read metav voice book I mean that guy's
always got something going
on um you've
you know if you you can't you can't stop
and breathe and it was really hard it's
really hard for me to even Savor a
success because I'm like it's such a
short period of time that you get to say
oh the numbers are good oh this is
happening because you haven't been
working for a month because you know
post has been polishing the thing that
you
submitted and you know you don't don't
waste that don't waste the time between
something ending uh and whatever you
hope is coming down the pike and you
getting out to try to look for something
there is no time to just
sit on the other side of that coin is
give yourself give yourself the
opportunity to savor the winds I didn't
do that okay and I paid the price for
that I worked you know 21 years I took
one vacation in 21 years I took one
vacation and it was to go to my
roommates destination wedding in
Barbados and you've never seen anybody
so stressed out on a on a cruise ship
that was you yeah I was just vibrating
the whole time I was on the ship just
like oh God I got to get back and I
couldn't get I mean I was at C so there
was no cell reception unless you wanted
to pay out the
nose and it was just like I I can't like
I I don't know what to do like we gotta
we got to get back and it was it was 10
days if you can't take 10 days off once
every 10
years you deserve what happened to me
which was I had a stroke and that put me
on my butt for a month and a half and I
was in no condition to work for probably
a month or two after that because I was
trying to figure out how to get my left
arm back which was a little more
important to me
than you know getting on to the next
thing you got to take care of your
instrument and that is you and your
brain so be nice great great Point as
Larry says eat well and get a good
mattress that's what he tells all of his
students when they graduate it's like
eat eat well and get a good mat and
you'll be fine because the quality of
your sleep matters and what you put in
your body
matters and preach preach preach preach
I'm sorry no no I I think it's important
to share your story if you're willing to
I mean well yeah I I I had I had a
wonderful agent for many many years and
she was always like well you know if you
let anybody know you've ever had any
kind of a medical issue then it's going
to be this whole big deal about whether
you're going to be reliable on the shoot
and this and that and the other and I
said I'd rather people know that I can't
I can't work an infinite number of hours
for you because a it's not
necessary and B it's not good for
me you know I I like good TV but I'm not
willing I don't want to die for it I
haven't come up with a clever enough
Epitaph to be dead
yet don't go on a cruise don't go on a
cruise because you're going to worry but
what if you did go on the cruise and
hadn't worried it it's the the job still
the Maria Bamford joke that she told 15
years ago which is she takes on these
Personalities in her comedy she says my
this is me and my agent on the phone
she's like Maria you can't go on
vacation because I had a client that
went on vacation for two weeks and you
know what he does now he drives a
rickshaw like they just forgot about him
in two weeks and it's like it's not
quite real but it's close enough to real
that it's like if you can't you can't go
off the map so if I'm not working I'm
sending people cards or I'm
you know trying to trying to have lunch
which is a real thing like the Hollywood
let's have lunch isn't about let's go
hobnob with famous people it's about
let's make sure I don't get
forgotten well you had an interview with
a gentleman who
said and I don't know how true this is
but find four restaurants yes and go to
those four you want to tell us the story
yes is one of the earliest pieces of
advice I got I always when I meet a when
I meet a big producer I say what's the
best midcareer advice you have for a
producer I don't want to know how to
break in I'm in like what's the M best
midc career and he said do you have your
four yet I said what four and he goes
you need two great restaurants and two
dumps and then one of those on each side
of the Hill meaning Beverly Hills the
valley it says only go to those places
for 20 years and he goes and what that
does is if you ever have to take a
meeting you say why don't we meet at
such so and everybody there knows who
you are so you get treated like the pope
when you come in they're so excited to
see you how nice to see you again
you have a regular table somewhere if
you can do that because it makes you
look like you have some kind of power
and presence in
town and it sounds silly I mean I had
people I told that advice to somebody
once and they were like that is the most
vain thing I can imagine is like well I
have a regular table at such and so when
Gary Marshall died every time I went to
the smok house I said I want Gary
Marshall's table Friday night at
8:00 so I would always sit in a table
that was associated with a very
successful person before me it's all
about absorbing the energy of the people
that aren't there anymore that's why
when like a famous person's house goes
up for sale it's always way over asking
because somebody's like I'm going to
live in a house that Frank Sinatra used
to live in or I'm going to live here
because this person lived here in the
40s they've been gone for 60 years it's
not they're going to pop out of the
closet and go you have some trouble with
the ovac 2 that's not how that
works but you're absorbing the energy of
the Dead sort of by being able to say
like well I have this regular
routine I do this this is where I sit
and again when you come in you have a
feeling of authority in slump that has
translated to when I feel terrible and I
feel like there's no way that I'm ever
going to get things back on track I go
to the same restaurants I'll go to muso
and Frank I'll go to The Smokehouse
those are the restaurants I've been
going to for 20 years I go there I sit
by myself in a booth that I used to sit
in all the time and I say everything's
going to be fine
and you feel like you're at home when
you're not in your home and it helps you
feel like the whole world isn't
collapsing around you because you still
have these little pillars of normaly
scattered around that you can go stand
behind so the roof doesn't cave in on
you let me ask you this when you go to
the two quote unquote Dives and one
person's dive is another person's muso
and franks because some people enjoy
diner food whatever what are those you
don't have to tell me what they are but
where do you sit and how do you know
someone of importance sat in that little
booth well usually I ask about the
history of the restaurant or why you
know why somebody's there there's a
place it's not a dive it's just not
fancy it's directly across the street
from Warner Brothers and it's called el
carpentero it is a wonderful little
Mexican restaurant and the guy that runs
it
Hector uh had always wanted to have his
own place opened that he's had the same
three or four waiters
forever and they're the only only people
you ever see and I got to the point
where I was on uh I was at a new
restaurant once and one of the waiters
there had gone to work at this other
restaurant and he's still at he's still
at El
carpentero but I walked into the
restaurant and I was like kind of
getting the lay of the room and whatever
and this there's his hand on my back and
he goes try what are you doing here and
it's like instantly I'm family at this
new place sure because this waiter
remembers me because I went there all
the time and I tipped like a Pasha like
you just had you it's it's make that
place important to you and understand
how restaurants work like if you go to
the Palm for lunch you're not going to
sit in a booth because everybody in a
booth is going to be the head of this or
that or an SVP somewhere and all the
unwashed get to sit in the tables around
the room like all the people that aren't
as glamorous or exciting are not in
booze they're just scattered around
during the open dining area on the
tables so that illusion though is
important it as as vain as it sounds on
some level like Chuck freze that I that
was the guy I got that advice from about
your two and two and just go there for
20 years he tells a story in the doc
there's a documentary about chason's
which many years ago was the of the
moment place to go and he walked in and
he said I could see these other tables
he goes I'd always get seated in this
one area but I knew the first tables up
in the front so I was like how do I get
to those tables cuz then I'll know I'll
really you know I've really got a
presence if I get to those tables and he
basically eventually ended up sitting at
tables in the front that like where
Hitchcock used to go for lunch and like
all these huge players and that made
that made him feel good so much about
this business and and your longevity is
about knowing how to make yourself feel
good and value
yourself and people are very quick to
say oh you know it's oh you got a
terrible ego it's like no I have
achieved things it's about your mental
health to feel like you have earned a
place and you
are somebody if no one else is reminding
you that you're a
somebody most of us are fairly unsung
I've done hundreds of hours of
television and I can walk unmolested
through the streets of any major city in
this country no one knows who I am or if
they do they come up and they go you
look like Carl Ro did anybody tell you
that it's why I don't wear Wireless
frames anymore you look like Carl Ro
that's great I'd rather look like
somebody uh you know somebody else but
but that being said that that it's
important important to feel good
especially when you put so much time
into a project but then you said
something maybe it was off camera about
having an outlet outside of the industry
and how important that is it it's it's a
matter of knowing where to go to feel
good about
yourself and to have those places
whether it's certain friends like some
of the best days of my life even now are
had in rooms that are basically a ratty
couch and Christmas lights and old
posters of the cockta
Twins and it's like why am I
here and it's just be like well you know
30 years ago I used to enjoy being here
and now I can just go and just melt and
hang out with a friend and listen to
music you know and people that are
obsessed with Fame and start hanging on
to famous people it's the saddest thing
in the world because it's like those
people most of the time even if you're
genuinely friends with them they don't
know who you are or there are so many
people pumping through your life that
you don't you know they they don't they
don't have time to commit to you know
these friends that they've made in the
last few years they still know people
that they went to University of Florida
with 40 years
ago so uh hanging on to something that's
real
yes and it's it's easy to do and and
food is an easy way to do it which is
why I always say
restaurants um it's it's a place where
you can become part of a community it's
that whole cheers thing you know you
just want to be where everybody knows
your
name and even if that's you know some
guy that's just bringing you your drink
or you can walk into a place and they
know what you're going to order so it
just comes to the
table that's the
best I watched a guy many years ago I
was at the Polo Lounge and I saw a bit
another won't name the name big alist
celebrity comes in they seat him his
salad comes out of the kitchen in like
30 seconds the McCarthy salad
and it's like he's been coming there for
so long they know what he wants and
they're going to bring it out to him
immediately or they know he has a
reservation at noon and it's just ready
when he comes
in there's got to be a wonderful comfort
in
that I'm not quite there yet I don't
have that shorthand anywhere but being
okay with if you don't have it that you
have outside interests and you wrote
poems and you've got have some developed
relationships with people that maybe
aren't in the industry as a way to keep
keep yourself grounded yeah and have a
personal project once in a while which
you do and it's that thing where you
know you have to ask yourself every once
in a while this is an Aly Willis thing
it's like you know does it have soul
like this thing that I'm working on does
it have soul that woman has so many
crazy little personal projects it was
just shocking you'd be like oh and I
also did this animated short it's like
oh I didn't know you did that oh yeah
this new animated shorts coming out in
two weeks and this is going to happen
and this is happening I've got this side
project here that she had more control
over as a personal project so that she
felt like she could really invest all of
herself in
something and I always say like for me
the most important thing is that I'm
making something that appeals to an
audience that people are going to
receive very well there are small things
I do that have way tinier audiences when
I did comic books I published a comic
book that no joke had 160 copies ordered
by the distributor it cost me more to
print the book than I made on the book
because it was such a small run and I
paid so much to the color separations
done for it and I never went back to
comic books again but I have one thing
that I can look to and go this is my
comic book here's the intro by Weird Al
Yankovic which is the only reason
anybody bought it because it was one
more thing that Weird Al had his name
on but that was it and I was like I got
to do this and if you made it it's
legitimate that's the other thing you
know I've self-published books on Amazon
as well as working with Publishers and
I'm as proud of the stuff that I did by
myself on Amazon without an editor as I
am with anything that I had published
through anybody because it was mine and
it felt like something I should do I
wrote a book called and another thing
about the TV notes process Which is far
from being you know the biggest selling
book in the world because it's about a
very Niche thing but it was a thing that
was all the all the knowledge I had
about something that meant a lot to me
and I figured somebody would identify
with it and I have a lot of EXA and
assistants and people like that look to
that book for their first experience on
how to give and get notes without it
being a contentious
process which is part of my general
Mission I don't think that making
television should be a contentious
process we're all part of making
something amazing that will hopefully
live for a little
while so why not have a good time doing
it